[Music]
the Hollywood beauty brigade took over
the met for last night Chanel Paris New
York Fashion Show also their metallic
maven Blake Lively look at those
embellished white boots oh I'm in love
no sight of hubby Ryan Reynolds maybe
because he's working on his song and
dance skills at least that's what Hugh
Jackman wants us to believe every time
he rings me it's like please can I come
on your show I'll come on as Deadpool I
just want to dance I want to sing with
you know my dude look I would love that
but a yob for it so Ryan that's a
challenge to you can you see can you
dance and if so shall we
now that's a challenge we are into
especially now that Hugh's gearing up
for his first world tour Hugh Jackman
the man the music the show he'll be
dancing and singing all of his favorite
show tunes including some of his most
famous feature film hits
[Music]
I'm secretly the year's wished I'd had a
lot of time to invest in dancing and
singing because I love it he was hoping
for some other famous friends to join
him on stage like this mother-daughter
duo
I really shouldn't be doing this on
camera because I've written a letter
which I haven't sent to her yet but one
of my dreams would be it would be a
dream if perhaps just one of my concerts
you would come sing a million dreams
with me on stage and bring willow too if
she's up for I don't know how you feel
about that but I wouldn't love her to
come to but the greatest show man's
toughest critic just might be his wife
of 22 years Deborah she's not into
musical theater like her hubby and he
told us she tends to fall asleep in the
theater the greatest compliment I've
ever gotten is that my wife has been to
my one-man show about 40 times and as
she said I'm gonna put it in her words I
didn't Apple once I might put that on
the poster
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]